[Music]
greetings
warriors of the arena my name is riku
and today we will be doing a new card
reveal from hearthstone's latest
expansion rastakhan's rumble
rastakhan's rumble introduces new troll
champions a new overkill game mechanic
and a single-player rumble run game mode
introducing a new contender to the arena
the minecraft
the line cracker is a seven drop neutral
card with five attack and ten health and
it has the newest mechanic overkill once
triggered it doubles the minions attack
and of course to give a more in-depth
analysis on how this card is gonna work
in the world of hearthstone let me
introduce
lambie series and sequinox from
resurgence
to
the arena
hey guys what's up hey
are you guys doing though
yeah i'm super excited about the card
and of course i want to learn more about
it so
what are your first impressions on
linecracker right so when i kind of
walked in i realized that i was thinking
that maybe i won't be done with it
when you think this guy looks very
familiar it's big it's green it's
muscular it's pulling the little guys
kind of like our favorite uh hulk
contouring
yes and
of course like you mentioned that it's
an epic so it's like a purple gem
and purple gem in avengers is the power
stone that's right i just got the
reference yes
it's so fitting so aesthetically i think
it's really really cool i really like
this really nice art yeah
all right so we already discussed about
first impressions how about any class
synergies you immediately thought of
first class that i talked about was a
druid actually because druid has a
superior ramp to other classes so i was
thinking of like this we go growth and
you go coin nourish and on turn four you
get this big bad boiled out seven out of
five ten against most aggressive that
technically they can't deal with it
because they have 10 health and it's
interesting because also basically even
if you want to go wide on the court
right like they're all so small this
color doesn't open up and it's just
gonna get bigger so it's like punishing
players for extending on the board yeah
so if it sets up like the counter kill
you know like yeah like you feel like
you're threatened but now that you have
this minute
it's like defensive
aggressive that's usually tend to want
to ignore that one big minion and just
push face but in this case they can't
because they can't even put anything
down because it's just gonna get
internal and it's gonna get bigger aside
from druid that you guys mentioned any
other class that come into mind
so personally for me when i first looked
at linecracker the one thing i wanted to
do with this guy is to buff it
and for it to attack multiple times
yup so in xiamen we have this card
called win fury and also win speak up
the first one being a spell and the
second one being imminent so what they
do is to actually give another minion
win fury so with this minion having win
free you can actually attack into a
minion first and then after you can hit
the face immediately for like tons of
damage wow yeah and like you can buff it
with cards like other mike flametown
totem so i think it would be a pretty
good fit in shaman right and i realized
there's actually one more interesting
because like when uh supernovas
mentioned that you can hit multiple
times right yes so your attack goes up
but your health goes down okay so when
your health goes down then there's this
kind of shaman as well it's called
ancestral healing so what happens is
that it recovers the full health and
gives it horn so which is crazy with a
mineral with like 20 attack and 10
health yeah yeah
so like further supplements the fact
that
nothing gets true yeah that's that's
crazy you're gonna get a lot of value if
you especially the wind fury mechanic
onto lion cracker imagine probably an
instant 20 damage
40 oh
that's crazy
so we're done with druid and we're done
with shaman any other class that you
think would synergize well with line
cracker well there is actually one more
that comes off the top uh which is rome
basically a rock has its own mechanic
which uh
most other classes don't have which
yeah so what happens with stealth is
that once you kill the minion right uh
technically this line uh
will be exposed but if you stealth it uh
thankfully nothing touches it so it's
definitely gonna survive uh more or less
to the next turn so uh for stealth cards
there is master of these guys in minion
form for uh rogue and of course in wild
uh sadly it's gone but
conceal
one of our favorite cuts back then yeah
give stealth for everything protects the
line
so yeah that's one of those things that
rope has so we're done discussing class
synergies we've got shaman druid and
rogue how about any
card synergies that you can think of
all right so okay basically the overkill
mechanic actually rewards uh destroying
opponent minions right so what happens
is this guy uh hungry at him six mana
four attack ten health it's a torn but
uh it's a great stats but there's a
downside which is actually that when you
play this card the battle cries that it
spawns a two cost minion for the
opponent now obviously when you spawn a
two cards minion is technically usually
quite small so uh the linebacker just
picks that up so that car actually goes
in line with like crackers you can play
that card
line cracker they play that card
yeah support the small guy that like
right destroys that guy yeah so it gives
you like a target to hit you know yeah
okay so other than hungary there's also
another card that does almost the same
thing also but it's only in warrior so
this is called corner century which is
like a two mana two six tom minion which
spawns three one one rectus yeah for
your opponent so instead of just having
one minute hit it we have now three
three one minute
awesome so it's like you know
having being able to trigger the
overkill mechanic easy
so now i'm actually curious riku where
do you think this car will find a
movement the first thing i i thought of
are you know pre-stacks in general my
favorite part
yeah because it has a lot of heels out
of buffs more adds more survivability
survivability to line cracker and one
thing that was interesting i was
searching through the internet i found
you know
an increased deck
yeah an odd piece tag that utilizes
glitter moth which can
really help out you know
maximize and get that healthy double the
health of linecracker and
i don't know how that fits i mean it's
crazy we were talking about it and we
were laughing but what do you guys think
i i think it will be fresh you know i i
don't know where the new expansion comes
out i think it will be really cool to
try this out thing
hasn't ever seen i'm just curious to see
it yeah
please do it
let's let's let's do that i'll try that
out
i think the most realistic thing and the
like the thing that she said that made a
lot of sense was that actually priest
has the heel hero power which actually
really really increases the
survivability of the like
but i know lastly we do have one thing
to discuss as well maybe just to put it
out there what do you think you know how
this card fits in arena
arena
disclaimer okay we are constructed
players we don't really play arena
okay
this card actually has pretty decent
stance actually it's pretty great stacks
for yeah
so i think it would fit uh quite well in
the arena i'm not sure what here but
it's gonna be pretty bad yeah because
normally people would pick like the
seminar five night right the first aton
in arena so this like plus one hell so
it might see more picks in the arena i
believe i think steps are pretty
important yes that's and as well as the
threat of the overcome mechanics
so we already discussed about you know
how amazing linecracker is in the world
of hearthstone how about any weaknesses
that come into mind all right
so uh
the cards that are coming out in
russia's rumble so there might be new
potential cards that might you know try
their best to protect overkill millions
so we'll see and hopefully you know that
puts this weakness out of all right
for a limited time only make sure to log
in right after rastakhan's rumble
releases to get six card packs for free
one legendary loa minion and of course
two spirit minions for the same class
for free
and there you have it remember
rastakhan's rumble launches on december
4 so see you all in the gurubashi arena
[Music]
you